hey what's going on it's bill burn it's
time for the Monday morning podcast for
Monday December 16th 2009
oh my god what's going on holy [ __ ]
there's only [ __ ] 9 days left 9 days
until Christmas do you know that's what
they always do there's only 90 more
shopping days to tell crazy through that
long time they never counted down to
Hanukkah you know there's only [ __ ] 6
more days till they never did that they
put all the pressure on the Gentiles
[ __ ] I'm sick I was fighting off I was I
was doing the Emergencies and then I was
[ __ ] drinking plenty of fluids and
everything was going great all right
everything was going great and then last
night we had a big holiday party here at
the at the at the house you know it was
a [ __ ] great one we had we had a
great one I can't believe my daughter
slept through it we had the [ __ ] UFC
in one room we had adults you know
mingling and mangling whatever the [ __ ]
they do right in another room and then
we had outside I had like they were at
one point there was like 20 [ __ ] guys
smoking cigars and all stupid bill went
out there without a hat on Oh bald Billy
stupid you know I had a nice little
[ __ ] sweater on some Christmas
ensemble on I felt like I could put the
hat on it was gonna ruin went all
Hollywood you know I didn't put my
health first and now I'm paying for it
[ __ ] thing it's been you know you
ever watched Lee and I've been watching
these [ __ ] animals killing other
animals lately I don't know why I'm
watching it's [ __ ] me up in the head
you know whenever I go to do Rogen's
podcast he's always like dude you see
that bear that ate that [ __ ] moose
alive it's like no III don't I don't
want to see that and they put it on do
[ __ ] bears Jesus Christ you know what
the you know I understand what a reptile
doesn't kill
before it eats it cuz reptiles do not
they're [ __ ] dopes they got small
brains they don't know what they're
doing they just grab onto something
their facial expression never changes
then you get to mammals we call gum you
know we got emotions you know our
eyebrows move right these [ __ ] bears
they just grab [ __ ] and then they just
hold it down and start taking chunks out
of the backs you know I'm a whole new
appreciation for that Leonardo DiCaprio
movie where that bear was holding them
down and [ __ ] throw and that's
exactly what the [ __ ] those things do
jesus [ __ ] christ those are the
goddamn baboons where they get the
little gazelles just [ __ ] snap its
neck how fresh does the meat have to be
I don't know what the [ __ ] I'm talking
about here and so I went outside I was
fighting this [ __ ] off like yes I felt
like you know like one of these [ __ ]
[ __ ] animals grabs another one and
you're rooting for come on man get away
get away get away you they you know that
[ __ ] elk every time he'd charge him
the [ __ ] bear would run away that
he's just keep doing that keep doing
that stab him right in his [ __ ] fur
yes they did then also the bear came up
a are you doing you know I can't talk to
you for a second he puts his [ __ ]
armor on his back and and that was it
that's why this cold is bad for like I
don't know three four [ __ ] days and I
thought I fought it off you know I was
being a good boy and and I didn't said I
feel like [ __ ] [ __ ] you know my
daughter she a no she was playing with
some kids [ __ ] you know they're at
that age it's just like if she comes
home with something that she gets it
that it goes through the [ __ ] house
and I thought you know they should stop
making those they should make like
parental hazmat suits you know if when
you kid gets sick cuz you're still want
it you love your kid you still want yes
I think that's what I did I came into a
room and she was coughing up a storm she
was laying there and didn't want to get
up and I was like what he want to do you
know she stretches with me in the
morning it's hilarious but she makes the
same noise as I make like she thinks
part of stretching is going on oh she
doesn't need to make those sounds but
you'll say dad I'm stretching oh right
so she didn't want to do that I could
tell she was rundown so I was like hey
you want that data you know laid out
what different she's just like yeah so
we're just hanging in there making jokes
making each other laugh and I think
that's where I got it that was it that
was [ __ ] it so and plus I was rundown
[ __ ] right all around but anyways you
know I was just watching the [ __ ] TV
they they got the sixes hey you know
it's commercials I don't give up on the
polar bears you know don't give up on
the polar bears it's like I am who the
[ __ ] said I gave up on the polar bears I
haven't given up on a nation what the
[ __ ] am I supposed to do about a polar
bear why don't why don't I mean I would
literally need a [ __ ] army of people
the level of bloodshed in world leaders
that I would have to take out in order
to save [ __ ] polar bears it's just
like I mean I am too far down the
[ __ ] road of my life to go that route
stand-up comedian turn rebellion leader
yeah are you [ __ ] people out there
scrape together your nickels and dimes
to save these [ __ ] these these these
animals what you need to be doing you
got to put together some sort of group
okay that's gonna [ __ ] walk in to one
of these oil corporations like a
goddamned like De Niro or The
Untouchables with the baseball this what
you're gonna have to [ __ ] do cuz
these people don't give a [ __ ] they
don't give a [ __ ] they don't think it's
their fault they don't believe it that
[ __ ] passing it off and they [ __ ]
own the government there you go there
you go alright [ __ ] sit there give me
a lecture [ __ ] [ __ ] as long as up you
know as long as they're there [ __ ] up
north I don't like a beat in a zoo
okay I think they should be able to
[ __ ] wander around where they're
supposed to be up top top of the planet
you know I relate to them on one level
cuz I am the same colour don't give up
on polar bears what the [ __ ] is that you
know they always
[ __ ] put it on you if you notice that
[ __ ] the [ __ ] government [ __ ] up
you know we're gonna have to tighten the
belt sorry it's the most this has to do
that I have a [ __ ] cult you know I
just sitting there going on [ __ ] am I
gonna get up and go get some goddamn
link we'll all right the [ __ ] head is
throbbing
alright I've been laying along the last
few nights I haven't been doing stand-up
trying to [ __ ] beat this thing then
one of the things that I learned is the
secret to the Bruins success this year
is that I don't watch them you know I
sat down and watch this leak they
[ __ ] lost Ottawa they lost the
[ __ ] Washington they lost the Tampa
[ __ ] Tampa okay somebody please
explain to me how Tampa has professional
sports I have you ever been to Tampa Bay
these [ __ ] PE you go to a game down
there it's like you know two or less
felonies get you a plus-one to go to a
[ __ ] Devil Rays game oh don't say
devil race don't bring up the devil you
know while I feed my neighbor to a
[ __ ] alligator I'm sorry I I don't
mean a stereotype it's not all they got
some great cigars down there you know
although I do think that [ __ ]
redheaded [ __ ] who started a [ __ ]
religion then he was boat down there or
some [ __ ]
every time redheads take a step forward
you know somebody quits the show and
tries to have a movie career or a
redhead [ __ ] start to religion and
it's just it just sets us back you know
Here I am trying to be neutral trying to
assimilate to a world of brown and black
hair the occasional blonde which for
whatever reason is celebrated you know
they're not freaks they're [ __ ] God's
okay I get it I get it yeah I [ __ ]
bathe in Hellfire
alright I get it I see how this I see
how this game I see how it's set up
now what color Corvette would you rather
have huh
competition orange [ __ ] Stingray or
would you like to have one that's canary
[ __ ] yellow I don't get it in a car
orange wins I think red wins I don't get
[ __ ] yellow Ferraris and [ __ ] like
that I remember this I never [ __ ]
understood that anyways we fly we hit
here all right so I'm sitting here right
dealing with my [ __ ] lack of pigment
[ __ ] miserable the [ __ ] Bruins are
losing and then just the cherry on top
was his death that don't give up on
polar bears all right let me send you
some [ __ ] money okay do you know what
I want I want your [ __ ] W whatever
the [ __ ] I need to look at the end of
the goddamn year how much of that
[ __ ] money is gonna go help a goddam
polar bear and how much of that is going
towards your [ __ ] mortgage all right
I told you my new thing I don't give to
these [ __ ] charities I walk up to the
what will it you know I walk up to the
[ __ ] person do you have the disease
that I want to help out good here you go
here she has 20 bucks you know you
[ __ ] bring a polar bear over here
right now I'll [ __ ] write in his palm
pain you know slip it in like a [ __ ]
tip in the dormant keep a little [ __ ]
what I get huh who bagged a [ __ ] seal
me I do love watching those things sneak
up on seals though you knows big fat
blubber [ __ ] I didn't know [ __ ] it by
the way I didn't know that leopard seals
killed penguins I had no [ __ ] idea I
mean they got they got a dentition like
a [ __ ] German Shepherd I should have
known they were eating something I just
thought they were eat another fish
there's nothing sadder than watching
[ __ ] Nate it's just [ __ ] brutal
you watch any nature show it's basically
it's like the news 40 Penguins went out
to go fish today and only 39 came back
yeah so it so is still missing and they
sent out a search party yeah my god it's
[ __ ] where do you turn you turn to
sports that's what I do you turn to
[ __ ] Sports and you watch your
get a little bit of omed to beating the
one in 12 Cincinnati Bengals defense
look great offense was you know was
doing its thing you know we got to do
something like that it you know next
week is the big [ __ ] test the Buffalo
Bills
the former [ __ ] bullies of the
goddamn AFC East Jim Kelly left and so
did their dominance it just went out the
[ __ ] window he realized that guy he
only played like ten years in the NFL
believe he was a Houston gambler before
on the USFL that which one of those
games did I tell you that I went to see
the Boston Breakers against the [ __ ]
Washington Federals and Nickerson Field
what is he historical significance of
Nickerson Field I didn't know this
Nickerson Field was actually the
original Braves field where the Boston
Braves played who I believe Babe Ruth
finished with them he could believe it
came back to Boston I think I don't I
don't know that well but anyway I didn't
realize that I was age to go to games
they're all tell when I was a kid my god
used to take us all down we go see the
BU Terriers play whoever you know some
reason 19 1997 they just got rid of the
football program that's why I've never
quite been a BC Eagle fan because you
know all my relatives went to bu
initially and so I never got into the
Eagles I did root for where they had
[ __ ] Flutie and was it Glen Foley I
don't know the [ __ ] old man I'm an
old sick man I can literally feel my
heartbeat beating behind my [ __ ] eyes
right now oh [ __ ]
anyway yeah the Patriots look good some
crazy ones though huh the 49ers [ __ ]
lost to the Falcons I was watching my
kid all day I missed that Jesus Christ
and then Seattle got back on track
they're beat Carolina they were winning
pretty an allele in the only one by
seven so I don't know what happened
there but I'm sticking with it man I'm
sticking with my pick the Baltimore
Ravens play the Seattle Seahawks
and I don't know now baby don't think of
the Ravens I think Seattle woods it I
think they were the NFC you know
although what about Green Bay all of a
sudden huh they put the Bears to bed
tuck them in all right
I believe they secured a playoff spot or
something like that I have no [ __ ]
idea what's going on I just look at the
[ __ ] scores and I just start talking
oh look at the [ __ ] Lions what do
they do
I'm sticking with that all right there's
something for football fans out there
any time you listen listen to somebody
before the season start before the
season starts and they're doing their
Super Bowl predictions that's the
dumbest [ __ ] ever I don't even give a
[ __ ] if they're right if they're right
that's like watching somebody hit a full
court shot you know it's just like okay
you know if you do it long enough you
[ __ ] eventually one's gonna go in you
can't listen to anybody to like like
[ __ ] mid-october six weeks in okay
you kind of start to see who people are
what they're you can make a prediction
that's why I love Paul virzi Paul virzi
is a mid-august watches a couple of
preseason games and he goes all right
here's my Super Bowl prediction are you
ready
you always ask you if you're ready are
you ready and he said Green Bay in New
England I was like all right well you
pick an Aaron Rodgers and you're picking
the defending Super Bowl champions okay
we'll see how that pans out right I told
you this [ __ ] that [ __ ] three weeks
in he goes Duke gradually he actually
congratulated me he said it was [ __ ]
over it's unbelievable because I think
we beat Miami that weekend anyway all
right let's let's move on
the podcast here where the [ __ ] is my
laptop actually bought a [ __ ] I don't
know why I know why I bought it I bought
a [ __ ] just stupid ass what the [ __ ]
you call those for those tablet things
what he called iPads but a [ __ ] iPad
it's how much I don't give a [ __ ] about
this [ __ ] but I just need it for my
goddamn job
I bought that thing it stayed in my
backpack for like [ __ ] four days
that's how much I don't give a [ __ ] and
the lady at the stores like you want to
help me you want me to help you set it
up and I was like yeah I do but I don't
want to stay this story I didn't say
that but I that was my thought I do but
I want to get the [ __ ] out of here so I
chose that so tonight I went to go set
the [ __ ] thing up and for the first
time ever I actually knew all my
passwords I was able to set it up and
everything for the most part went fine
and then I tried to put on the
waterproof case and you know I'm like a
[ __ ] chip I just ripped open the box
I'm please wait if I put together like
some [ __ ] IKEA [ __ ] I just lay it all
out I take my time I just go into this
[ __ ] zone I've not flipped out
assembling anything it's in in like
[ __ ] ten years I don't know what
happened I kind of [ __ ] I beat that
demon right but this [ __ ] I [ __ ]
iPhone iPad [ __ ] laptop [ __ ] so
anyway [ __ ] trying you know
everything went fine setting the thing
up I'm like holy [ __ ] I think I did it
iron I already snapped today because I
[ __ ] my phone updated and I took a
landscape photo and I wanted to make it
like regular which I knew how to do and
that I had to spend ten [ __ ] minutes
trying to figure out how to do something
that hour you know maybe one thing if
there was a [ __ ] reward at the end of
it there just isn't it's [ __ ]
ridiculous I literally go online and
then every videos from like 2013 it's
like that's not the
operating system I have how to [ __ ] it
blah blah blah blah blah then I find all
there's the button it they they moved it
up
so everything was going [ __ ] [ __ ]
fine right and then I go to put the
[ __ ] waterproof case on the [ __ ]
thing they got this whole stupid [ __ ]
Jacques Cousteau test I'm supposed to do
like sticking in a [ __ ] bathtub
without the thing in it for a half hour
and then take it out and then see if any
of the contents that they give you to
stick in and are wet it's like I don't
have time for this [ __ ] I'm gonna go
swimming with this [ __ ] thing
so I blow it off there the process of
blowing that off I lost the instructions
and I'm trying to stick the find iPad in
the front of the [ __ ] thing and I
just lied alive I you know I just
[ __ ] lost not too bad you know cuz my
kid was came into the room so I [ __ ]
chilled up and then I just sat there
[ __ ] you know seething this stupid
[ __ ] thing I was trying to stick it
through the front of it they literally
give you a key to [ __ ] open up the
sides of it I finally got it in and I
thought I had I got something you know
recover the screen but there was this
blue hard piece of plastic and had all
these [ __ ] words on it I was trying
to scrape it off and I couldn't know
like I the [ __ ] do I get this [ __ ]
thing off and it turned out that that
blue thing was just for the what I
thought was the screen protector was
just for the [ __ ] half-hour water
test that I'm supposed to [ __ ] do I
don't know that this is just [ __ ]
stupid then what do you know I I have
another lap I have a [ __ ] iPad
somewhere in my [ __ ] house that works
and I just can't remember the password
and I cannot figure out the [ __ ]
keyboard the whole [ __ ] thing I just
I don't know where the charger is
anymore
and I'm not throwing it out because it's
gonna end up in a [ __ ] ocean or a
[ __ ] polar bears gonna try to eat it
so I just I just haven't
weird so for people over right they
brought their kids over right these two
guys are like best friends they sat next
to each other they young you know late
teens or something like they just sat
next to each other hanging out just
looking at their phones one of the few
times ever I was actually like really
happy that I you know I don't know the
more I look at this the way the [ __ ] is
now I'm really happy that I grew up when
I grew up you know I got to have a
[ __ ] childhood before anybody at
school could just show me somebody
getting [ __ ] in the ass by a horse I
can't imagine what these kids show each
other with these [ __ ] phones right
there wasn't [ __ ] porno all over the
goddamn place I could enjoy the four
seasons you know the change of seasons
and all of that [ __ ] it wasn't just
[ __ ] you know a hundred degrees or
[ __ ] minus ten now Jesus bill find
the [ __ ] light we don't all have a
head cold you have [ __ ] freckled [ __ ]
Oh bye I got the light right here
alright maybe even the lights my episode
it's not my episode the episode that I
was in on the mandalorian the massive
Jon Favreau guided Star Wars so and so
whatever the hell are you supposed to
say it aired on Friday give it a watch
you don't have eight everyone's breaking
my balls about something on the thing I
don't should I do this spoiler alert
here I feel like I need to defend myself
all right I didn't alright spoiler alert
fast forward like a [ __ ] minute
alright you have you could do it in five
four three two wide 3/4 half put by this
is for [ __ ] people who like like
driving right now it just turned down
the volume start reaching for your phone
relax okay here we go you know and it
took me so long to do this somebody's
probably turning it right back on as I
say all right here's the
I didn't drop the baby yoga all right
that yoga I didn't drop the baby Yoda
okay the [ __ ] robot dude came out of
hyperspace and he didn't tell anybody
all right till you're in hyperspace
holding a [ __ ] baby and some robot
all right like that's not unsettling
enough is driving the [ __ ] thing and
slams on the brakes let's see how you do
all right walk a mile in my [ __ ]
space slippers before you [ __ ] come
at me I'm [ __ ] with people just
breaking my balls I you know I had a
great response so thank you guys for
watching it and thank you for all the
kind words and now that I've said that
I'm sure all the negativity is gonna
come in but I don't give a [ __ ] all
right I already did it
I already got the check I already spent
it on a [ __ ] iPad again that's it
it's over so anyway that happened I
actually watched the episode my wife's
always say you gotta watch yourself to
get a watch yourself I was like I'm
telling you right now it's it's not a
good thing to do it's not a good thing
to be looking at the side or the back of
your head while you're talking you're
watching yourself tits [ __ ] this you
know I don't know if the Native
Americans have something for that you
know you know they always had that thing
if you [ __ ] somebody takes your
picture like a piece of your soul I
can't imagine what they would think
about sitting down watching video of
yourself pretending to be somebody else
in a world you're not in anyways but I
did sit down and watch it only because
I'm into the [ __ ] show which is
hilarious about this whole gig that I
have like I always like you know I
thought you liked Blade Runner the first
one and the one with Ryan Gosling I
[ __ ] love both of those mood was Sam
Rockwell I like [ __ ] like that I never
got into the Star Wars thing but this
one this one this is the one that you
were waiting for it's like a [ __ ]
spaghetti western I've absolutely loved
this and been watching it right along
and anticipating and actually looking up
when episodes are coming out so
congratulations to Jon Favreau and
everybody over there
Rick family Wow hope I said his name
late last day right was the director of
the episode that I didn't he'd [ __ ]
crushed it anyway let me let me do some
reads here for the goddamn week hey
everybody don't give up on the polar
bears you know all right what the [ __ ]
am i doing you
what the hell's my password I forgot it
already right there we go then I typed
this in here because god forbid you know
somebody sneaks up and [ __ ] breaks
into my laptop and sees how I was
looking up the all-time pastors in the
NFL it's a really interesting list by
the way if you go and look at it you see
how long how long some people play you
know and how much the game changed
because of Bill Walsh with the [ __ ]
West Coast offense you know Johnny
Unitas was the first guy to ever throw
for only forty thousand yards and he
like the next closest guy during that
time only had in the 20,000th like he
was like the [ __ ] Wayne Gretzky of
quarterbacks as far as like he just like
double to everybody and uh but now like
you don't yeah I think like Vinny
Testaverde has more yards to him that
[ __ ] not Vinny I love me I'm just saying
you know Vinny Testaverde god bless him
he's not Johnny Unitas and I think vide
will be the first one to tell you that
as he put on a jersey for one more
wouldn't you love to see him come back
one more time was one of my favorite
[ __ ] things ever there was two
quarterbacks that just like Steve de
Berg you know I don't can't tell you how
many times I thought that guy retired
and then he would just be holding a
[ __ ] clipboard hold it a [ __ ]
clipboard I bet that guy I bet his body
feels great you know most of his career
was holding a [ __ ] clipboard and then
I don't know why he would come in and he
was just the coolest [ __ ] dude ever
70s had that curly noodle hair he's a
quarterback you guys this [ __ ] I really
read the [ __ ] what am I doing here
let me reread the advertising here where
the [ __ ] am i alright hymns you've heard
us talking about him and how they're
helping guys look
their best if you have it yet it's time
to see what they're all about
all right problem 66% of men's start
losing their hair by the age of 35 once
you've noticed a hair it could be too
late why do guys turn to weird solutions
or do nothing when they can turn to
medicine and science solution for hims
calm a one-stop shop for hair loss skin
care sexual wellness for men look at
this you get your hair back they clear
up your skin you dick stand it up
looking for some [ __ ] prey right all
right they watch too many animal fix but
those [ __ ] bears do they [ __ ] peek
up oh God
[ __ ] heartless thanks to science
baldness could be optional hims is
helping guys be the best version of
themselves with licensed physicians and
fda-approved products to help treat hair
loss no snake snake oil pills or gas
station counter supplements there's some
old references prescription solutions
backed by science answer a few quick
questions a doctor will review and if
they determine it's right for you can
prescribe you medication to treat hair
loss that is shipped directly to your
door try hymns today by starting out
with a free online visit go to four
hymns calm / bird that's fo r hims calm
/ bar for hymns calm / bar prescription
products are subject to doctor approval
and require an online consultation with
a physician who will determine if a
prescription is appropriate C website
for full details and safety information
this could cost hundreds if you went in
person to the doctor's office or
pharmacy remember that's for hims
dot-com / / hey you know what I you know
what I think I think one day when they
were they like have a quick cure for
baldness rather than a treatment like
like LASIK eye surgery you know you go
in and you got your eyes open and
literally you seen smoke coming off your
[ __ ] eyeballs alright and then they
go
right don't read anything for the next
couple of days which I'd be like the
perfect LASIK person never patient don't
read anything hey I haven't ready
thinking [ __ ] 12 years so you do that
[ __ ] right and then all of a sudden you
got 20/20 vision
you could go fight and fly the goddamn
space shuttle alright and but then after
like 10 15 20 years it goes to [ __ ]
right I think that that they're gonna do
that at some point they got to come up
with some something football this right
it's they're just gonna be [ __ ] laser
at the top he had smokes gonna be coming
off it you know is just sitting there
with the little [ __ ] tablet watching
a couple episodes of who's the boss
whatever the [ __ ] you doing right and
then you just got this [ __ ] wavy hair
for like ten years and then just all of
a sudden you go bald for the second time
[Laughter]
you know and they're all you know like I
cuz why are LASIK you can't get it again
so you got a time you know like I've
been fighting off getting glasses for
like six years like I won't wear them I
just feel like what you get glasses your
eyes are [ __ ] and I've asked that with
a bunch of people who wear glasses and
they all agree you know they all do yep
once I did that then they just they got
my don't say my eyes aren't [ __ ] but
they just get more they get [ __ ]
quicker you know it was epic sense I
don't want to talk about Bill alright
cool
stop you know what people hate more than
anything being bothered with little
daily annoyances you know like oh that's
written like a blues guy you know I hope
you know what up - oh now this more like
a stand-up comedian this guy knows what
I'm talking about
keep it going for Larry Larry Ahrens hey
are you doing you know you you're you
people yell what you people hate more
than anything be bothered with little
daily annoyances
this guy knows what I'm talking about
back yeah this was written by a [ __ ]
bad 80s stand-up comedian this copy
things like being stuck in traffic we're
waiting in line or just having to do
things you don't have to do how about
sticking a [ __ ] tablet into a
waterproof case that you don't give a
[ __ ] about well how the [ __ ] could be
waterproof the screen is right that I
guess that part's waterproof who the
[ __ ] is taking a [ __ ] laptop into the
bathtub is that how you kill somebody
you used to be a hairdryer [ __ ] radio
now you just throw a [ __ ] or does it
have to be plugged in I don't know
anyways well guess what you can get rid
of some of these annoyances just by
using stamps calm you don't stamps you
know about stamps calm
they've been sponsoring the show for
over seven years now and you haven't had
and you and if you haven't tried it what
are you waiting for it's coming up
quickly it said worried it started with
Halloween rolled into Thanksgiving the
holidays are coming up quickly gets sad
and with staffs dark rum today so that
you you're ready for the holiday rush
stamps.com brings all the services at
the post office right to my computer you
can buy and print US postage for any
letter any package right from your home
or office
you could even schedule a pickup with
the bail carrier so you never have to
deal with LA traffic at least for going
to the post office uh I guess we're okay
I have it I haven't even gotten to the
best part yeah but stay calm you get
five sets off every first-class step and
up to 40% off Priority Mail why would
anyone pay full price where they don't
have to stamps calm is a no-brainer
saving you time and money it's no wonder
over 700 thousand small businesses
already use stamps calm right now my
listeners get a special offer that
includes a four-week trial plus free
postage and a digital scale without any
long-term commitment just go to stamps
calm click on the microphone at the top
of the homepage a typing bar that stamps
calm enter bur stab stock
never go to the post office again yeah I
got someone else what's here everybody
all right
I've added two more Vegas dates next
year all right
March 21st Las Vegas Nevada that Chelsea
at the Cosmopolitan of Las Vegas and
then June 1st Las Vegas Nevada that
Chelsea at the Cosmopolitan of Las Vegas
there you go
artist presale Tuesday December 17th at
10:00 a.m. Pacific code burp B you are
our public on sale will be Friday
December 20th at 10 a.m. Pacific time so
if you go into a [ __ ] potty you're
going out there to do whatever it March
I'll be there and I'll be there in June
all right
Oh also by the way the Patrice O'Neal
benefit there's a few good tickets left
January 27th at the New York City Center
featuring Ronny Chang Judy gold
Sam RL Andrew Schultz Cypress sounds
rich Foss Roy Wood jr. and yours truly
it's gonna be a [ __ ] monster of a
show this is one of our best lineups we
got the best mix of the old with the new
you know people that were influenced by
him with people that actually knew who
he was actually knew him I should say so
that will be January 27th at the New
York City Center in New York City all
right
Jesus Christ okay this is you know it's
not that bad tonight's gonna suck
tonight's gonna suck trying to go to
sleep but then tomorrow I should be good
we got a good one tomorrow night Monday
night right who the [ __ ] blade hey
what the [ __ ] going on with the ramps
Jesus Christ they lost again I'm gonna
[ __ ] hangover and a half all right
so be wrote in about the mandalorian I'm
not gonna read this cuz I don't want to
[ __ ] ruining his [ __ ] this guy just
said that I did a good job but buppa
buppa ba yeah thank you guys for
watching it and it's really been cool to
uh you know my whole world has always
been like sports fans and loud drunks
and all of that so to have like this
whole new group of people coming up to
me you know the Nerds they're [ __ ]
cool too they're polite this smart
they're super into this you know the
stuff that you're doing
it's been great I'm used to like sports
fit a Billy red tits go [ __ ] yourself
love the podcast these guys are coming
up like hang uh just gonna are you the
guy that's uh in the middle Orion I just
wanna they're really [ __ ] yeah they're
they're really nice people so if you're
a jock stop stuffing them in a [ __ ]
locker at that nice people all right
oh we got an update here we got an
update I love when people give me an
update you know I start talking about
some of this [ __ ] I read these emails I
say write me back a most time be that
people don't or I are they doing I don't
see it so I don't people just don't give
up on polar bears okay it's on you you
need to not give up on polar bears not
not [ __ ] all these big corporations
you know you know it's not for their the
polar bears that that that's on your
[ __ ] shoulders by the way I'm going
to hand woods back for the Celtics very
excited about that even though for some
reason we can't beat the [ __ ]
Philadelphia 76ers who we all know if
they're not gonna do [ __ ] we know
they're not gonna do [ __ ]
okay actually look good
I thought you scared the [ __ ] out of me
as a basketball fan is the Lakers they
look [ __ ] solid they look [ __ ]
solid that was [ __ ] bastards they won
championship behind us too because they
count a non NBA title as a [ __ ] title
and there was also a mobbed-up ref that
helped him get by the Sacramento Kings
you know I just bring that [ __ ] up
because they're always [ __ ] on the
Patriots saying that they [ __ ] cheat
and meanwhile the [ __ ] Lakers could
say they have 16 [ __ ] champion okay
you know okay one of the referees went
to [ __ ] jail
that goddamn series and I've also still
convinced that game seven if that wasn't
[ __ ] fixed the last time we played
the [ __ ] Lakers
it was either fixed or I don't know what
Rasheed Wallace said to those [ __ ]
referees but they were just like [ __ ]
this guy he's not getting a ring call
30-something fouls on one team Italy in
the teens or the other in a game seven
put you a [ __ ] wizard we won't even
[ __ ] hack at him either who's the
worst game seven ever and it was the
Celtics versus the Lakers I can't get
over still bugs me to this day I
literally watched the Lakers rather than
[ __ ] Manning up and beat the Celtics
they stood taken free throws free throw
thirty ones free throw 32 for to the
game afterwards Kobe Bryant I don't know
how we won that game well go dry hump a
referee buddy that's how you want it get
him a new footlocker shirt all right
update girlfriend who wanted to stay and
exes for Christmas
dear pill bar look at that did you
should I be at all well it looks like
she's dumping me no there you go to
recap my girlfriend swung the idea of
spending Christmas with her baby daddy
to make it less difficult for the kid
yeah yeah yeah all right yeah but you
know what dude that's you're out you're
out
your girlfriend order you had a kid you
don't [ __ ] need that [ __ ] trust me
relationships are hard enough they're
[ __ ] hard unless you met a [ __ ]
sweetheart who for some reason dated the
biggest [ __ ] [ __ ] ever which is
every coming-of-age movie that Hollywood
has ever made the cheerleader you know
she's a sweetheart dating the biggest
[ __ ] ever I love how she wasn't a
[ __ ] on any level
it was always put on the guy right and
he was a total dick and then this
[ __ ] nerd comes over and you know
ends up banging her you know you know
why it always worked out like that
because writers writers write that [ __ ]
they were writing how they wanted their
high school to go anyways the guy says I
approached the situation just like you
said calm and collected I didn't even
open up and even open with the negative
but instead presented the wonderful
dream Christmas I would put on for the
both of them followed with I just hate
the idea of you spending Christmas at
his dacha thought she said I don't have
to worry about that because he
respective respectively declined
I found myself still irritated at the
fact she even asked but remain calm you
gotta remain calm I should take that
advice then a couple days later I sent
her a good-morning text and she
responding saying I'm a good guy but she
would like to talk ooh yep ok my feeling
is that this douchebag is playing some
game along the lines of as long as you
have a boyfriend
holidays are going to be very stressful
for you and I'm going to make sharing
this kid very difficult you might be
right but you know what dude you don't
need to be in this [ __ ] so yesterday she
tells me she doesn't want to do this
anymore
over text all right yeah you know maybe
she didn't want to see you cry I know
you know something if somebody broke up
with me over text I mean I you know I
could get over that I get it the
technology exists people use it why
would you want to go face-to-face would
breaking somebody's heart if you could
just [ __ ] dump it out on your phone
[Music]
it's a coward way out really well why
don't you walk to work and quit taking
your car that's the coward way to work
what because it's [ __ ] easier anyway
I convinced her to talk in person with
me tomorrow though so we'll see how that
goes the shitty part is I already bought
her a gift that I can't really return
because they're all very customized but
you know what you can't also return is
the [ __ ] amount of years you would
have wasted with this person what do you
get involved in this Jerry Springer [ __ ]
yeah
you got your whole [ __ ] life ahead of
you you know
she [ __ ] that guy without a condom you
didn't wanna [ __ ] she to ruin your time
I whatever you bought her I would use as
a stand to put a little [ __ ]
kegerator on and drink a couple of
[ __ ] beers I know it sucks right now
because you're going through it but I'm
telling you look at this from the
outside you don't need this [ __ ] guy
uh this [ __ ] guy come we didn't
[ __ ] up your relationship anyway
stuff uh anyways she hasn't changed her
status on Facebook but has hidden it oh
dude you're looking at her Facebook
account as is bad this is I feel bad for
you buddy anyway so I guarantee you
she's being unfaithful it's all very
confusing because not two weeks ago she
was gushing about getting married having
kids moving in it was very clearly in
love with me we both been together for
over two two years I think she's
thinking good clearly and irrationally
how do I convince her to stay
you can't it buddy I know this sucks
right now cuz you're going through this
[ __ ] but [ __ ] walk okay this is like
if you could somehow get into your
logical brain this is what your holidays
are gonna be like every [ __ ] year
okay it'd be one thing if this was a
former [ __ ] boyfriend but she had a
kid with this guy this guy is in her
life for 18 to 22 [ __ ] years every
[ __ ] time there's a major event in
their kid's life that [ __ ] guy's
gonna show up or or you can you could
get you know cry this out [ __ ] you
know give yourself a good three months
to be like what the [ __ ] was that cry it
out it just [ __ ] move on and have a
new thing I am NOT [ __ ] dating
somebody that as a kid all right
that is not your [ __ ] problem that's
like your [ __ ] you date somebody that
has a [ __ ] kid that is literally like
god bless you if you do but that is like
[ __ ] that'd be like me watching one
of these superhero movies that that one
that took like [ __ ] ten years you
know they made like 15 [ __ ] movies if
you jump in it or like the [ __ ] knife
would you could like like you're gonna
know what's going on it's probably a bad
example because I'm sure that they make
it easy for people so they can get more
people to watch it I don't know dude
you know what whatever you want I hope
it happens all right but I'll tell you
this just from the outside looking in
[ __ ] her dude she doesn't deserve you
all right
I don't know how that I can't you know
I'm not gonna say something positive
about her cuz I don't want to drive you
back to her cuz my gut is saying just
[ __ ] walk these boots are made for
walking and that's just what they'll do
one of these days these boots are gonna
walk up to a chick who doesn't already
have a kid do-do-do-do-do-do-do but pop
up up up up up up alright alright b2
forgot for calling your girl cute oh god
why did we ever let these [ __ ] let
him out of the kitchen man I'm telling
you I'm [ __ ] with you but you know so
I gotta be honest you got buddy mine
sent me a text he went on a date with
some chick he kissed her and she said
like a [ __ ] Constitution the next day
talking about the kiss and how she felt
and what she wished she said all he did
was kiss her and she kissed her back and
then the next day she had all these
different having Jesus [ __ ] Christ
people don't give up with the polar
bears all right me too
calling for a girl calling a girl cute a
dear Billy Burgundy balls
I like that Burgundy's nice it's a regal
color I am a freshman at college in
earlier the first semester all of my
Hall mates and I were in a room together
hanging out we were be a little loud so
the RAS
come to the door to tell us to be quiet
be be the closet opened the door what B
being the closet the closest sorry got
him stupid that was a legit [ __ ]
I read that his closet and it's not
because I need glasses
it's how I read it me being the closest
opened the door and I saw a girl
standing outside with the RA with the RA
badge on some of the room asked me who
it was and I said some cute girl in a
joking way they are all this is a power
thing you disrespected her badge the RA
asked us to quiet down because it was
late that left once I closed the door
this super liberal girl in the room said
why did you call her cute Oh
oh my god because I thought she was cute
this is that all right anyways I said I
was only joking that she said that's
seriously not out cat all right here's
what you need to do right now is get
that person out of your [ __ ] life you
need to apologize to her I said what are
you talking about I'm not apologizing
for complimenting someone and that
everyone else in the room started saying
how creepy it was and that I needed to
say sorry oh my god I feel so bad for
this [ __ ] generation jesus [ __ ]
christ but when I was when I bring it up
now they all say they were wrong in the
bull but it wasn't actually creepy yeah
they all caved because they got nervous
with this [ __ ] other person anyways I
just think this is a good demonstration
of how ridiculous College is getting and
how over-the-top feminists are some
feminists to be fair you can't even
compliment a girl anymore without
sexually harassing her anyway anyways he
wrote a great I just thought you would
find this interesting and have some good
commentary about it really love your
stuff and go [ __ ] yourself yeah I mean
what you know what you do with people
like that you just listen to them you
let them you know let them have their
fit it'd be like okay all right that's
it
no comment or whatever and then you just
cut that person out of your life you
know what somebody like that in your
[ __ ] life some [ __ ] [ __ ] just
trying to stir things up you don't I
love about that whole [ __ ] thing is
the person you said it to the person
like if they said that they were
offended even then it's like what the
[ __ ]
you know it's not like she was walking
down the street by herself yeah you're
cute
I can't understand how that's annoying
there's a bunch of other people there
men and women or whatever it's [ __ ]
harmless somebody else like I don't know
I know that's a big white chick thing
they like to get offended for people who
did get offended I don't know what it is
I think they're just bored all right
girlfriend or Ivy League yeah I would
literally I swear to god dude I would
just this is this is think whatever you
see that woman who gave you [ __ ] about
that [ __ ] this is what you do you just
[ __ ] you do nice her to death hey how
you doing whatever you do a little
compliment to though Oh si how you doing
sweetheart you can't say yeah yeah you
do it Bubba
you know just how are you good to see ya
no matter how Kunti she is you don't
give it to it that's it she's out of
your life All Right girls Fred or
ivy-league GI RL d/deaf RIE Adi
girlfriend our Ivy League hey Belle oh
wait you know something I haven't played
this in a little while have I
hey that's me else all right with a
[ __ ] where did it go I had all right
it always goes to Jeff Beck voodoo did
babe a baby boo all right
ahh hey Belle I'm having a little bit of
a dilemma right now and I was wondering
if you could provide me with any insight
hey you know I'm not an expert but if
you ask me a question I'll answer it
I've always been that way even in class
what is the numerator 17 no that number
isn't even in the problem hey you asked
me a question I'll [ __ ] give you an
answer anyways I'm a senior in high
school but I'm dating a sophomore in
college
oh god yeah you need my advice I need
your advice she goes to college a couple
hours away from where I live we met in
high school and I had a decent amount of
experience with girls yeah dude you must
be doing some right but this girl is
something completely different
I could truly be myself around her the
problem is I applied early decision to
an Ivy League school dear me early
decision as a form of application that
include I love that you know that I
don't know what that means
okay I like yeah you are a normal you
are a regular listener of the [ __ ]
podcast early decision is a form of
application that includes a contract
stating that you are fart if that if you
are accepted into the school you must
attend that school wow dude nothing like
desperate or something like that
that sounds like some [ __ ] you know
where they [ __ ] draft some [ __ ]
kid out of Kentucky they make like a
rule that he has to play hoop for a
certain amount of time before he goes to
the [ __ ] Lakers because that's where
they all go all right early decision is
a form of application that includes a
contract stating that if you are
accepted into the school you must attend
this that school all right applying
early decision gives you a better chance
of getting into the school because Ivy
Lee
don't like it when they accept students
who don't end up going to their school
you know what hey [ __ ] those guys you
know it really has to be this push back
with regular people this whole [ __ ]
thing you know from [ __ ] frequent
flyer miles to this [ __ ] horseshit
[ __ ] American Airlines foot to call
me the other day I know it's about my
stupid [ __ ] miles keep the miles
[ __ ] call me up with your threats oh
you gotta use these but do I do I gotta
use them by that day take a back I don't
give a [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] interrupted
my goddamn day like I give a [ __ ] about
you and you goddamn miles I [ __ ] hate
that [ __ ] we don't like accepting people
that don't hey you know I don't like
being [ __ ] $600,000 in debt and not
having a [ __ ] job afterwards 600,000
I would beg there
what's the Costco I believe for 100
grade a year but 25 they'd put you above
500 grand right anyways I was already
already was accepted into college that
she goes to which is also a great school
but I know I would rather go to an Ivy
League school if I could get in alright
you know what I gotta be honest with you
my guy I that that's that's that's that
still needs something I really still
does mean something you know anyways I
find out tomorrow if I get in or not and
I'm probably over esterday estimating my
abilities debating this but I know I
want I don't want to lose this girl any
advice on how to proceed with this
situation or any advice on how to tell
this girl that I got it if I do would be
greatly appreciated I'll send you an
update once I hear back love you stuff
and go [ __ ] yourself this is easy just
sit down calmly you just say sweetheart
I love you to death but it's not my
fault that obscure than you did you
promise her that you were gonna go to
her college how far away is the Ivy
League school
you gotta watch out though you know you
go to Dartmouth you join a frat you got
to eat the vomit I don't know but look I
would just you know I [ __ ] applied
it's an Ivy League school I want to go I
still want to date you
what is the [ __ ] I mean it I'm in high
school we go in a different school now
we're still dating what's the difference
here's the deal you're [ __ ] young all
right you're really young you're banging
a [ __ ] sorry there's your girlfriend
you're you're in love with a sophomore
in college and but you know dude you
can't turn down go to an Ivy League
school you gotta [ __ ] go all right
then if she really loves you she'll let
you do it okay that's the deal then you
could very easily spin it well someday
you know we get married I'll have an Ivy
League degree which will give me [ __ ]
a six-figure job somewhere we can live
like kings and queens right or I could
go to your but a school though Kenny
look at this I'm actually becoming
arrogant on your coattail stuff possibly
going to an Ivy League school
all right jesus [ __ ] christ by god
damn those all right here we go wrapping
it up here a journalist put on earth for
you dear Billy deep throat that is a
reference to Watergate everybody I used
to be more of an or a portal depending
on what side of the tracks you're from I
used to be more of it I can't even
[ __ ] breathe Jesus Christ you know
what I hate about fighting off a cold
and then you still get the cold is you
don't get credit for the days you were
fighting it off like rather than it be
in three days it's only one day it's
like this [ __ ] cold I should have
just [ __ ]
gave into it it would have been over
came on Thursday here it is Sunday I'm
still battling with this [ __ ] thing
you know what bill you did fight it off
and then he went outside you didn't wear
a [ __ ] hat it [ __ ] idiot the hell
was I talking about
Oh a journal there are I used to be more
of a traditional Democrat Democratic you
guys are just as dumb as me I used to be
more of a traditional Democratic but
what the way things have gotten I found
myself agreeing with your perspective on
politics well what is my perspective my
perspective I'm kind of like you know
Irish I am liberal I'm on the blue side
but I respect people on the red side you
know the first hundred rows and I expect
them Dukes you know the first hundred
rows of my side you respect each other
you listen to each other you find a
common ground that's what I like those
people in the [ __ ] back screaming and
yelling those [ __ ] lunatics drinking
out the parking lot on each party I'm
not into those people
anyways I started paying attention to
international journalists instead of the
ones served to me domestically that's a
great move I'm not saying that those
people don't lie too but it's good to
you know hear what their life sound like
and try to figure something out
I follow one in particular who reminds
me of you she has no problem taking
flames to any president or party I can
hear you saying after all her tweets
here's a good one I already love this
person it's great to know that there's a
[ __ ] journalist out there doing this
okay Bush and Obama both invaded nations
on lies Bush and Obama both bombed
weddings and hospitals Bush and Obama
both armed terrorists Bush and Obama
both murdered and uprooted millions of
innocent civilians yep values are the
same oh wow and then they have a picture
from Yahoo entertainment of Michelle
Obama's says she and George W Bush
disagree on policies but their values
are the same that's [ __ ] hilarious
all right Sarah
Abdallah at SAH oh you are a XO I'm
gonna be following her follow Jimmy door
Jimmy doors like that great [ __ ]
comedian too anyways I feel like this
could really give you material at
Hollywood parties you want to leave in a
kerfuffle I do it I don't do I'm old
school I don't bring up religion or
politics you know you don't do that you
just you don't I'll be not doing it in
stand-up [ __ ] around try to piss
people off you know but like I don't I
don't [ __ ] do that [ __ ] anyways
thanks for dedicating your life to
making all of us a little happier
have a wonderful holiday with your
beautiful family you lucky redheaded
turnip well you guys make me happy or
when you laugh at my jokes he listened
to the podcast so it's all it's all
working here all right overrated /
underrated underrated the tow machine at
the gym
awesome carnie oh and practically a full
body workout especially for your back
biceps forum and legs yeah dude
I've never seen anybody who religiously
goes to that thing is pretty [ __ ]
shredded I remember Ari Shaffir when he
was doing the the [ __ ] Rogen sober
month thing he was on that thing he was
[ __ ] shredded I was like god dammit I
gotta quit booze and get me one of those
[ __ ] rowing machines is that what the
Toba sheet is that's not a picture and
it is right wait no that's the roba
sheet why you guys listen to this
[ __ ] thing honest what it's a Toba
sheet - yo W by the way for anybody as
dumb as me tow machine that is what it
is all right okay all right I thought it
was stupid there for a second why don't
they call it a Roma sheet maybe somebody
hold the name and they didn't want to
get rid of it all right also for a
little for as little as a thousand
dollars you can buy one that's foldable
so you can have this awesome workout at
home anytime did you just slip an
advertisement in here because goddammit
now I'm gonna look that up maybe this
will get me abs foldable let me see this
NordicTrack
but I always liked Nordic Trek we bought
that [ __ ] thing way back in the 80s
you know that cross-country skiing thing
well let's see let's look at some videos
here let's see what people are up to The
Fault this is something called the
folding rowing machine on YouTube is it
this something oh that's [ __ ] weak
that's [ __ ] bad Jesus crave [ __ ] that
thing [ __ ] that [ __ ] that okay two
thumbs down on that let me just see a
regular [ __ ] tow machine okay I said
row machine let's see it the toe one is
better all right that's for a boat I
don't want to
Thoma sheen foldable there's a foldable
[ __ ] thing to put a boat on I'm gonna
put my [ __ ] boat on it alright tow
machine for home now [ __ ] that you know
what you want you want the [ __ ] here
we go commercial level
towba sheen now looking at trailers are
you sure this isn't a rubbish it's gotta
be a row machine right alright just want
it [ __ ] it I give up I can't even
[ __ ] look up a goddamn piece of gym
equipment and I'm not good at it right
okay that's it thank you to everybody
who was watching the mandalorian and
thank you guys so much for i got a real
kick out of what you guys all said I
really appreciate it you know what I
mean
you know I've done some acting I've done
a lot of acting so it the fact that you
guys like what I did especially in a
world that I wasn't supposed to be it
was [ __ ] awesome thank you to John
Rick and everybody else over there who
[ __ ] hooked me up with that gig and
also this was Saturday this Saturday
night I'm gonna be in uh I'm gonna be in
Las Vegas yeah that that but though to
do I'll be what's up with Trump here on
my dumb jokes talk about your dick do a
[ __ ] joke make fun of a fat guy I'm
gonna be doing that I'm gonna be there
this Saturday night with Dean Del Ray
the del razor and I got a whole brand
new hour of [ __ ] and I was gonna run it
tonight but I'm [ __ ] sick so I will
be down I'll be down the comedy store
all [ __ ] week that's why--that's
except I don't think Wednesday I'll be
down there but I'll be down there all
week I'm gonna try to run by our in the
belly room Tuesday night I'll be down
there Monday I'll be down there Thursday
I'm gonna [ __ ] you know shake the
cobwebs off after fighting off this
[ __ ] colder than losing fighting than
losing it's like I [ __ ] got it to the
overtime and I lost to the shootout
alright that's it thank you for
listening to my [ __ ] moaning and
complaining go [ __ ] yourselves that I'll
check in on you on Thursday